des annonces alors qu'il ya un nouveau
samedi de mobilisation contre le pass
sanitaire s'organise aujourd'hui à paris
et parmi les rassemblements celui des
gilet jaune qui a démarré aux alentours
de 14h30 du côté de la bibliothèque
françois mitterrand
à lui calé j'ai accompagné d'olivier
molinari est en direct de ce cortège
lucas 13e samedi d'affilée donc
l'ambiance par rapport au douze derniers
samedi qu'elle était là
et bien eu quelques tensions entre les
gilet jaune qui se trouve au premier
rang de cette manifestation et le
cortège deux gendarmes qui encadre cette
sedan tech vous pouvez voir qu'ils sont
tous présents ici sur ces images
d'olivier molinari les mots d'ordre
restent les mêmes libertés les
résistances ces personnes veulent que le
pass sanitaires soient purement et
simplement abandonné que le pays se
réouvre totalement alors même que selon
heureux et bien la situation sanitaire
est beaucoup plus favorable que cet été
et ils s'inquiètent aussi pour les
enfants alors que pfizer a formulé nous
demande de mise sur le marché de son
vaccin pour les 5 12 ans états unis
craignent aussi purement et simplement
que la vaccination ne devienne
obligatoire je proposais
quelques manifestants avec qui j'ai pu
parler au début de ce cortège
on pense qu'il ya d'autres manières de
faire que de d'imposer un pass qui fait
une sorte d'apartheid en fait il ya des
gens les gens qui n'ont pas le pas
salutaire ils ne peuvent pas ne peuvent
pas aller à tel ou tel endroit est ce
qu'ils ont ils peuvent donc ça fait
vraiment une séparation des personnes
c'est pas de choix contre les vaccins
les vaccins ont rendu par le passé de
nombreux services mais j'ai pas
confiance dans ceux là dans celui ci et
j'ai pas confiance non plus dans ce qui
me nous incite à le prendre mal fait à
le faire faire voilà c'est une question
de confiance en réalité et aujourd'hui
on en train de nous dire qu'on va nous
faire payer les tests pcr alors qu'ils
sont là juste pour protéger la
population et aussi si on nous les a
imposées jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est pour
protéger la population je ne suis pas
contre le vaccin je suis contre
l'obligation vaccinale qui est
totalement
différente pour moi donc chacun a le
droit en fait douvres est normalement
avoir le droit de payer liberté de
choisir pour son corps c'est que
j'estime juste pour moi et qu'on arrête
de nous dire que le bassin sanitaire
c'est quelque chose de sanitaires ça n'a
rien à voir fin septembre il y avait 9,2
lyon 2 personnes éligibles qui n'avaient
pas été vaccinés il y avait par ailleurs
14,4 pour cent des personnes souffrant
de maladies chroniques comme le diabète
qui n'avait pas complété leur schéma
vaccinal du côté des professions
soumises à la vaccination obligatoire il
y avait eu il y avait 1400 personnes
suspendues en ile de france il était mi
septembre
3000 dans toute la france selon olivier
ferrand mais ce chiffre pourrait être
plus important enfin le syndicat sud a
de nouveau appelé à la grève dans le
secteur de la culture contre le pass
sanitaires
merci lucas léger pour toutes ces
précisions directement du défilé anti
passe sanitaire des gilet jaune merci
aussi à olivier molinari qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra